[Música]
no solamente para estar clarito que es
lo que hago yo debía una información yo
soy el biólogo de todo lo demás nuevo o
sea lo que yo me dedicó principalmente a
es tratar de entender por qué la gente
toma las decisiones que toma y cuánto
esas decisiones son animales no sé a
cuántos de nosotros es todavía animal ya
veces uno cuando escucha esto puede
decir este terrible que me llamas animal
no pero en realidad si nosotros
entendemos lo poderoso que es lo
instintivo lo animal y aprovechamos ese
poder instintivo para lo que nos podría
hacer mejores seríamos extraordinarios o
sea no hay que darle la espalda a la
animalidad que llevamos dentro hay que
disfrutarla y aprovecharla y eso es un
poco lo que vamos a hacer ahora utilizar
nuestra animalidad para fines en la que
vamos a hacer mejores personas empecemos
entonces intentando responder esta
pregunta porque hacemos lo que hacemos y
no lo que debemos hacer osea conozco a
muchísima gente y seguramente yo también
soy un estrés en algunos momentos que
tenemos
planes este quiero bajar de peso quiero
hacer deporte este quiero comer más sano
quiero terminar las tesis aprender otro
idioma quiero emprender conozco gente
que hace 200 él está emprendiendo y
nunca también emprender siempre están
pensando y me pregunta por qué pasa eso
y al final terminamos echándole la culpa
a la voluntad no le decimos a más que no
tengo fuerza de voluntad es que me falta
la voluntad es que ayude nacido con esa
voluntad hay una frase de hecho que es
que cuando la escuché sms medio milito
que decía el infierno es el lugar donde
tú te encuentras al final de tus días
con esa persona que pudiste ser pero no
fuiste porque te faltó fuerza de
voluntad
cuando llegaron las personas fueron
ciertos no fueron porque por
supuestamente fuerza de voluntad está
claro que la gente que tiempo es
increíble pero qué pasa si tu fuerza hoy
viene no y ahí es donde creo que podemos
nosotros cónyuge porque sin embargo esta
gente que que en teoría no logra cosas
hace cosas con mucho esfuerzo o sea esa
gente que en teoría no tiene gran fuerza
de voluntad hace cosas interesantes por
ejemplo terminamos la universidad muchos
de ellos terminan una carrera trabajan
para una organización para una empresa
por lo tanto trabajamos 8 10 horas se
levantan a las cinco de la mañana
atraviesa en el el tráfico regresaba a
su casa tienen hijos
a sus hijos o sea hay mucho esfuerzo ahí
entonces aquí en el mundo del de las
sillas y nosotros nos preguntamos por
qué por qué por qué puedes hacer muchas
cosas con mucho esfuerzo pero no puedes
hacer otras y tal vez es que hay
factores externos que estimulan a que
esas cosas sucedan factores externos
muchos de los instintivos que despiertan
en nosotros una fuerza que ayudan a que
la reacción suceda en la química hay un
concepto que se llama catalizador que es
un catalizador es un factor que hace que
la reacción se acelere se haga más
rápido se haga más pronta entonces pero
comenzó con la química hay catalizadores
y utiliza este término también en la
conducta humana hay catalizadores
conductuales están apuntando no están
apuntando si hay catalizadores
conductuales que nos empujan a hacer
cosas que nos inhiben a hacer cosas y
muchos catalizadores pueden ser animales
puede ser el instinto que llevamos
dentro
así que llevamos dentro del
australopithecus afarensis que está
todavía en nuestro cerebro o sea por
ejemplo digamos que aquí estaba una
persona y está reventada la personita
esta personita está haciendo y lo
deseado es que ahora x de acuerdo
entonces un día de alta motivación de
alta fuerza voluntad esa personita a la
radio a trepar la soga va a llegar hasta
ellos y lo va a hacer día 2 las
personitas y entusiasta sigue motivadora
poquito menos que ayer pero sigue
motivadora te paras ahora y hace equis y
no hace y está bien está bueno pero te
servía dice lo cosas que ya mejor
después el lunes empiezo de estas
maneras esas que mejor mejor es que ya
nos quedamos haciendo más total nuevo
tan malo sea más o menos bien sucede eso
es bastante común y por qué pasa eso
porque siempre es complicado hacer algo
algo nuevo
versus lo que estoy haciendo tiene
hojitas ahí tiene lapiceros si quiero
pedir es en este momento probablemente
nueve segundos 9 segundos para que
dibujen rápidamente
una flor vamos 987 vamos amigo 6.15
estudiante un 4-3-2-1 tiempo
quiero que comparen la flor que han
dibujado con la flor de su compañero
vamos a ver qué cosas sale
listo es muy probable
pero muy probable que el mérito has
hecho es exactamente igual o muy pero
muy parecido a las flores de compañía
porque porque hacemos lo que siempre
hacemos imágenes x y yo les hubiera
dicho quiero que por favor dibujen una
casa de gm de su mente por favor dejen
en su mente y ustedes dibujaría esta
casa
con su mente nos abre la ventanita
redonda que vemos es un pitufo
clandestino no funciona si no somos así
sin embargo cuando yo te acelero te
angustia
flor porque somos decir porque cuando
hay espacios de angustia o de falta de
fuerza de voluntad yo hago lo que
siempre hago lo que siempre he hecho
hacer algo nuevo para nuestro cerebro es
generar un puente de neuronas nuevo y
eso es ciento de proteínas y eso cuesta
calorías y nuestro cerebro quiere
ahorrarse siempre quiero ahorrar ella
volvió de la imagen nuevamente está el
señor aquí el señor chiquito que quiere
lograr el que está haciendo y de acuerdo
para lograr yo para empujarlo a cara x 9
y tengo que hacer difícil o indeseado en
fácil lo deseado o sea literalmente
tengo que hacer que se mueva esto lo que
vamos a hacer ahora hoy día yo le voy a
dar catalizadores conductuales que les
va a empujar que le va a estimular que
lo va a motivar a hacer cosas que
querían ustedes no puede
a 0 entonces empezamos a afrontar estos
ojos 6 catalizadores que les van a
cambiar la vida primero esta frase la
escuché una vez
y decía algo así como si tú quieres que
tu equipo construye un barco no empieces
dándoles funciones herramientas no no no
lo primero que tiene que hacer es
pararse en el acantilado mirar el océano
e imaginarse lo maravilloso que va a ser
navegar en un espacio eterno infinito tú
estás mirando el océano y te estás
imaginando y cuando te imaginas tu
cerebro siente que lo está haciendo lo
está disfrutando y cuando lo disfruta
aparece la hormona del placer o sea la
dopamina entonces la vanidad te dice si
por ahí sigue siendo seguirá siendo el
barco por favor sigue haciendo y tú lo
vas a hacer cada vez con más ganas de
hecho la gente que viaja por ejemplo
siempre está imaginando su viaje y por
eso viaja tres veces con otros viajamos
una vez será viajar los tres porque
viajamos cuando pensamos que vamos a
viajar hoy vamos a hacer esto vamos a
hacer es increíble viajamos cuando
viajamos y viajamos cuando ya hemos
viajado cuando reunimos a recordar hoy
cuando te robaron si que no te robaron
increíble hasta hacer esas cosas nos
pasa lo imagina lo que es y lo que
genera las hormonas que están asociadas
en este caso la dopamina entonces
catalizador número uno visualiza osea
disfruta lo que vas a disfrutar siempre
te imagínate que ya estás ahí y eso va a
hacer que tu cerebro siga haciéndolo si
así lo pero porque siempre hay un pero y
las historias pero uno que empieza en
pilares y que lo voy a hacer para las
hermanas las hermanas
las semanas tranquilas y aniquilan el
entusiasmo inicial y tiene que recordar
porque lo están haciendo por eso que yo
me acuerdo que un amigo
militar me trajo una metodología muy
interesante él me dice que me decía que
cuando uno está en zona de emergencia
con una extensión de conflicto para
acordarse siempre algo se pone un
puntito rojo en su reloj incluso que le
puede incomodar ver la hora para que
para que cada vez que ve la hora se
acuerda se acuerden que alguien le puede
estar apuntando la cabeza y los puede
matar yo sé que usted es nadie más quien
más tarde apunta la cabeza lo que ellos
quieren es saber que tienen que estar
alertas tienes que estar con el cortisol
hormona del estrés prendido en el caso
ustedes tienen que estar con la dopamina
prendida entonces tiene que pensar dónde
en qué lugar de la casa del cuarto la
oficina ponen algo que los estimule
hacer lo que quieren hacer entonces a
catalizador número 18 visualiza apuntado
a donde vuelven en su memoria duden de
su hipocampo el hipocampo y sé si sí
pero este rito lo borró dijo next
siguiente
esta historia me parece de paso siempre
fabulosa aparte tienen atrás
a una cuestión psicológica muy muy
interesante
ulises ulises quería ir a ver a penélope
entonces quería y tenía que atravesar
los mares y la diosa le dice ulises
suave suave que están las sirenas y las
ideas que van a cantar y cantar y tuyas
de buena forma de mandar tu barco a ser
un amor hito por las puras tanta guerra
te vas a morir ahí así que yo sé que es
un tipo muy curioso si vas a querer
escuchar a las sirenas no por favor
controlar ya está bien está bien está
bien pero luis esquer y escuchará la
sirena
entonces cuál está más cerca pero no
todavía escuchaban las sirenas les dijo
a sus a sus marineros marineros a masrb
en este mástil una primera mano pero
porque les amarre - más ustedes a marc y
vamos a pasar por el lado de las sirenas
quiero que ustedes echen cera de abeja
en sus oídos para que no escuchen nada y
tú también no no no yo quiero escuchar
pero bien amarrada no voy a hacer nada
cualquier cosa yo le di a ustedes como
mejor filme en gm gm y así pasó viajaron
y la sirena es un lío live en un lío
lindo o sea por favor
insultaba a los marineros
no escuchaba nada y seguir remando por
favor
pasó el espacio la ciudad no tome en
serio porque pasó y se murieron ellas y
lleva y el pudo contar su blog que era
el gran objetivo de los granos objetivos
de un viajero como él pero aquí está
interesante un tiempo moisés en qué
momento se amarró cuando estaban
cantando antes que se estén cantando
antes porque porque tenía en ese momento
fuerza de voluntad
la voluntad no es una fuerza constante
no es una fuerza permanente va y viene
según nuestro ciclo circadiano va y
viene según la energía que tenemos
entonces si no hubiera hecho el momento
nos encanta como hubiera podido hacer
catalizar mareos a marte
amarte así de bonito y doloroso o sea
ponte los candados cuando puedas ponerte
los no siempre vas a poder ponértelo por
ejemplo
en la mañana estás en pilar y ximo
entusiasta y así lo hago de todas
maneras metiendo la dirección de la
lechuga y tomate de y sólo eso estás
increíble de mañana y el almuerzo
promoví te aguantas y comes un poquito y
estás pero luego pasando las horas la
energía se empieza a ir empieza ya la
tensión y llegas a tu casa pasas por la
cocina y ves ahí un calentamiento
esperándote arrocito su frijolito su
payasito empieza por los bordes y fue un
momento importante
te he pedido el pero es bota todo eso si
tienes el teléfono comida chatarra bota
todo eso pero no vas a votarlo a esas
horas de las noches no vas a poder
porque hay unas ideas están cantando las
sirenas están diciendo como me comeré tú
tú no vas a poder hacer es entrada que
ahora sí lo puedes hacer cuando tu
voluntad está alta cuando haya calma y
energía o sea en la mañanita después vas
a olvidar esa toma esa decisión el abad
arrollar pero ya te va a quedar poco que
hacer y para compensar ese espacio vacío
con alimentos un poco más saludables las
peñitas bien picaditas en la ni estás en
la refri para que las conozca país algo
saludable y de esa manera vas a evitar
que las sirenas te canten entonces
segundo cual será amarrete amárrense
seguimos esta cajita le llama las
cajitas de la honestidad como funciona
en algunos lugares digamos una
biblioteca universitaria se pone una
cajita y se pone el café al costado
leche galletas y tu si quieres
consumirlo consumes y tú sólo te pagas o
sea servicio
funciona bien funcionan los científicos
para probarlo para estimular a que los
los estudiante sea un poquito más
honestos una semana pegaron ojos al lado
de la cajita de honestidad y para hacer
comparaciones la siguiente semana pues
pegaron flores de acuerdo
ojos flores ojos flores ojos flores para
ver qué pasa
miren los resultados
en las semanas que se ponían ojos
siempre se recaudaba más siempre había
más recaudación o sea los estudiantes al
bien eso que pasaría su cerebro
consciente un inconsciente pero los
hacía súbitamente más honestos este es
un comportamiento biológico evolutivo
darwiniano o sea cuando yo me siento
observado soy distinto
yo no soy igual en la mañana y en la
noche no soy igual con luz rojo con luz
azul yo cambio mi comportamiento
cuando me miran soy diferente que cuando
no soy mirado entonces vamos a utilizar
esa estrategia está ese ese
comportamiento instintivo un paso
exponente
es la tercera este es el catalizador
exponente punto en el ojo de la tormenta
que significa esto vas a buscar a una
persona a la que tú sientas admiración y
que te parezca que su opinión sobre qué
es importante o sea hay mucha gente que
por opinar cosas buenas o malas de ti no
te importa hay mucha gente pendiente que
sí es importante su opinión sobre ti y
lo vas a buscar a una persona es decir
amigo tengo este reto conmigo mismo y
quiero que tú seas el testigo entonces
cada semana yo voy a venir te voy a
contar cómo voy avanzando y sin
desaparezco o no avanzo me miras con la
mirada de desprecio donde abandona lo
tanto si no veo que lo que esté este
sobre ti que esté incomodando de acuerdo
entonces eso va a hacer que te empuje
por la observación externa
entonces cuál será el tercero
expone expone ocultes no te ocultes
seguimos porque la gente va donde la
gente
quiero oye quiero comer un cebichito muy
chiquita voy y me encuentro los chifas
un chifa lleno y un chiste vacío a dónde
van
pero si está lleno porque está lleno
porque nosotros mismos o por ejemplo
usted quiere una refrigeradora
refrigeradora y hay dos que tiene más o
menos precios más o menos los mismos no
sabes qué comprar y una dice la más
vendida el mes pasado
cual creen ustedes que la gente va a
comprar la más vendida el mes pasado
porque porque seguramente por algo
habrán comprado alguna razón será tal
vez son especialistas en refrigeradoras
ya no se siente cómodo porque los otros
han hecho algo y a eso le llamamos
comportamiento gregario nos sentimos
cómodos haciendo lo que todos hacen lo
que la mayoría hace porque porque nos da
protección a su comportamiento animal
instintivo evolutivo entonces vamos a
aprovechar esa fuerza para hacer lo que
nosotros queremos hacer y no lo que
estamos haciendo
o sea quiero que ustedes busquen a su
trío y hagan esto llegar y sense de
acuerdo de narices y ariza t como así
vamos a buscar a una tribu que esté
haciendo lo que tú quieres que lo que tú
estás haciendo si están bajando el peso
junte con gente que está bajando de peso
si estás haciendo deporte si estás en
deportista las noticias están
emprendiendo juntarte con gente que está
emprendiendo y que va a hacer compartan
su experiencia pues las investigaciones
sobre terapias grupales han sido tan
poderosas y eficientes muestran qué
cuando tú estás con tu grupo y se come
no los encuentro religiosos también de
fin de semana porque te hace sentir que
no eres el único raro de la historia
sino que hay muchos otros como tú aquí
como ves ahí ven ustedes todos parecen
iguales no pero no dentro de todos ellos
hay mucha competencia están compitiendo
parecen todos juntos pero son
compitiendo
y para que compiten y porque compiten la
competencia es una estrategia de
motivación extraordinaria tal vez no hay
cosa más poderosa para motivar a un
grupo que la competencia entonces que
creen que les voy a pedir además de
compartir un compite busca a una persona
y retales y dile compadrito yo voy a
bajar de peso primero que tú dices no yo
voy a hacer primero que tú y trata
además de buscar que sea alguien que
esté un poquito mejor que tú un poquito
mejor que tú porque las investigaciones
ha mostrado que cuando uno compite con
gente que está un poco superior a 11 te
la gana porque lo ves no es alcanzable
pero todavía está lejos avanza más
rápido te entusiasmas más eso es súper
súper importante para apuntar apuntado
entonces
cuarto puede ser el cuarto
muy bien organízate la palabra también
inventada y así que lo escuchamos
ahorita ahorita greca avisa de cosas
para largos caminos bastantes
provisiones
pero qué pasa cuando tu proyecto hace
unas dos semanas tuvo nunca te valorar
va a durar tu voluntad pero si tu
proyecto es de seis meses ocho meses un
año ya las cosas no es tan simple ya un
momento te vas a medio olvidarte
entonces qué vas a hacer
quiero que vas a hacer tú te vas a
premiar para cierto avance te das un
abrazo de recompensas de alguna manera
ojo pero no vale recompensarse con algo
que está en contra lo que está buscando
o sea si estás buscando bajar de peso
recompensarte con comida chatarra no
tiene sentido no eso no sería mucha
sería retroceder evolutivamente entonces
recompensado con algo que realmente
contribuya de acuerdo
además investigación que muestran que
cuando un grupo por ejemplo está muy
motivado es bueno enseñar en lo que les
falta para lograr el gran objetivo pero
no está tan motivado es bueno enseñar en
lo que han avanzado sea como sea
detenerse felicitarse y ver a alguno de
los dos lados va a contribuir a que esto
suceda
entonces cuál será el quinto
premià te abraza te quiere te de rato en
rato cerrado en moto al tiempo rato en
rato cuando hayas hecho un avance y aquí
está
para tomar decisiones todo el día
quieres tomar decisiones porque claro
que pasa sin decisiones siente que por
las horas está el cerebro entonces qué
hace el cerebro a veces tiene buenos
datos igual y toma buenas decisiones
pero a veces no tiene buenos datos pero
igual tiene que tomar decisiones y eso
no está le llamamos los sesgos
cognitivos o sea todas las decisiones en
base a 45 datos algunos le llaman a eso
los cerebros vallès ya nos por la
estadística vallès ya da los zerolos los
los seropositivos son muy interesantes y
que puede citar específicamente a dos
sirve confirmación y se jode
disponibilidad es la confirmación y
podría funciona más o menos así uno
tiende a encontrar los argumentos que
nos apoyan a encontrar los argumentos
que van según lo que nosotros pensamos
los argumentos que va en contra no lo
pensamos
pero que si está con nosotros es más
nosotros solemos encontrar las cosas que
está en nuestra cabeza todo el tiempo
dando vueltas y nos angustia por ejemplo
estrés o menstrual hay un retraso
menstrual adiós mi retraso y empiezas a
ver embarazadas por todas partes no eso
no es un mensaje de odio esto es un
mensaje dios no lo que pasa es que tu
cerebro lo tiene muy muy muy fresco o
sea está muy disponible y lo detecta es
más rápido y aquí viene el tenis cuando
uno está por ejemplo haciendo dieta
encuentra las frases perfectas para
dejarla
porque realmente justito
no está justito porque sea chiquito pero
es un payaso no es un pollito vamos a
gigante entonces hay que no es un
gustito por ejemplo ellos también lo
hacen no sabemos sólo agregar yo no lo
hace sino porque lo único que no
el clásico super clásico el lunes
empieza montó no hay salud empiezo
empiezo con todo lo que está diciendo
detrás de eso que hoy día voy a fracasar
eso es lo que estás diciendo entonces
una estrategia vas a poner estas estas
frases citas estas excusas las vas a
poner en una suerte de caja minera de
acuerdo a la caja negra y las excusas y
cuando las empieces a utilizar cuando la
simple utilizar qué vas a hacer primero
va a decir peligro hay una excusa en
camino peligro y que hace ser te vas a
delatar a ti mismo frente a quien frente
a todos los que puedas a ese testigo que
alguna vez modelo no lo llamaste para
que te ayude a la gente que lo que estás
compitiendo a ti mismo en frente a tu
espejo te vas a delatar y te vas a
incomodar y eso va a frenar esas ganas
de romper justo lo que tanto había
avanzado amigos entonces cuál será el
sexto
de la tate
les ha traído buenas noticias pero no
son tan buenas porque porque ustedes ya
tienen este conocimiento y eso les va a
fregar la vida antes yo quería que la
voluntad y como tenía poca voluntad
bueno no se puede no se puede ahora ya
sabes que no basta la voluntad las
estrategias estos catalizadores
conductuales realmente hacen el cambio
pero de ti va a decidirse si es que lo
gustas o lo no lo usas o sea puedo
volver a esta frase inicial la
cambiaríamos un poquito y de algo así
como dicen que el infierno es el lugar
que al final de tus días te encuentras
tú con la persona que pudiste ser pero
no fuiste porque nos hasta los
catalizadores conductuales amigos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]